hello I am Nikolai candle and I will
give you a presentation today on the
CRISPR cosmic technology and insect
population control during my
presentation I will go through a few
questions why do we need essentially
gene drives how does a crisper mediated
gene drive walk is anything joy Freddie
fulfilled application and do we have any
alternative or less invasive methods for
insect control insect are the most
diverse animal group they have a lot of
beautiful species but they also include
less appealing species presented here in
these pictures and you can divide them
into two groups the cultural past they
threaten food safety and disease vectors
they essentially threaten our lives they
transmit many disease and the next slide
show that the mosquito is the world
deadliest animal mosquito transmitted
for many diseases but they kill more
than 700 thousand people a year so
mosquito is the more prolific killer
than humans themself and it's nothing
compared to shock which killing ten
people per year these Flyers show the
transmission of Nene disease by by
mosquitoes one interesting point which
not many people know that it's only
mosquito female dream blood males they
don't drink blood there she will
pollinate some flowers and drink nectar
so mosquito dreamboat female bring blood
and transmitted pathogen and mosquito
female needs their blood to develop eggs
one interesting fact another one is that
it takes a while for pathogens who
include eight in mosquito and Mysterio
can transmit disease during the second
bite so in the first bite mosquito will
drink blood and essentially in fact
itself and then parasite will develop
inside the mosquito and then it takes
seven to ten days before mosquito will
ready for a second
blood meal and that that second blood
meal mosquito will transmit the
pathogens to humans we can intervene and
break the cycle by reducing number of
mosquitoes in the population or by
reducing lifespan of mosquito
because if mosquito doesn't live long
enough to by the second time it will not
be able to transmit disease we can also
essentially humanize mosquito made them
refractory so they don't get disease
themselves and they could not transmit
it only and will block this above arrow
of a cycle on a human site we can also
intervene we can reduce the contact of
people and mosquitoes we can vaccinate
people or we can give people to reputed
drugs and people will stay healthy and
nolde
develop a full-blown disease so a
mosquito will not be able to transmit
traditionally insecticides and allama
sides are used for all insect control
including mosquitoes the big problem
with that insecticides like a nuclear
bomb we killed all different kind of
mosquitoes completely indiscriminate li
and mosquitoes very rapidly evolve
resistant resistance to a particular
insecticide and they adapt behavior in a
way that they minimize the contact with
insecticides as I said insecticide kill
our insect for example nicotine or
insecticide they kill the pollinators
such as a honeybees and the continued
insecticides recently being prohibited
in Europe in addition many insecticides
they also in fact very conserved
function like a mother cordial function
in all animals and they are not healthy
even for humans and prolonged exposure
to old insecticides can induce
Parkinson's disease and some other
health problems in humans so what are
the alternatives
still all insect technique is very old
classic but
good working alternative for pheasants
insecticides in this technique large
number of insects aureus and the factors
they undergo some kind of radiation
treatment to induce chirality then from
this pool of mosquitoes which has
sterile females are removed and males
they essentially distributed in a local
population these sterile males in the
local population will go find females
mate with them and then female ax but
nothing will hatch from those apps so if
you do it multiple times and you use the
fuchsia numbers of mosquitoes releasing
each time you can reduce population of
insects in this method which is called
SAT is this tissue specific so it will
work on if one particular species it's
much more precise and as I said it was
proven effective technology and it was
applied since 1952 and the first insect
for which it was applied called the
school on fly these flies used to fly in
southern states of america and mexico
and they lay ax in alive cattles and and
even humans and bamboos eggs will hatch
and larvae will borrow and eat living
tissue so it's obviously not a good
insect and huge program still in sight
technique was initiated to essentially
reduce population of these school on
flies and very gradually it was
completely eradicated from southern
states of america Mexico and Central
American countries but these fishes
still fly and occur in southern America
and many still insect males of these
school flies are still released in
Panama to block the transmission of his
flies back into northern america this
program still insist technique is very
effective for some flies and still
currently used are shown in these
pictures still males of Mexican food
flies and Mediterranean flies are
released in taxes in California to block
transmission of his flies from Mexican
to the US however
Ct is not effective for mosquito control
and one reason is because there are no
good methods to remove mosquito females
from a pool of irradiated insects and
you don't want to release huge number of
mosquito males and females because
females bite and transmit disease
in addition released still males
mosquitoes they are not competitive
because they have a lot of radiation
induced mutations and they're they're
less feed than wild-type mosquitoes they
don't compete very well so what has an
alternative for the mosquitoes what
album efforts are available in the labs
many mosquitoes essentially were induced
to become immune to certain diseases you
can put some genes which called
refractory genes and block infection of
Plasmodium which will cause malaria
disease or dengue virus which will cause
dengue fever so this slideshow
publication where genetically modified
mosquitoes were created in the lab which
essentially could not get sick could not
transmit the disease
so obviously the logical conclusion is
if we can just release these genetically
modified mosquitoes in the wild and hope
that they will be plaid replace the
wild-type mosquitoes then we will have
less infected mosquitoes and less human
infections we can block some diseases or
at least reduce number of accidents of
this disease but there is a big problem
because transgene or disease refractory
genes which is in GM mosquitoes how do
you spread this gene through the
population you want to spread it fast
but there is a big problem genes which
are foreign genes that's why they call
trans gene they are obviously reducing
fitness of the carriers so transgenic
must use as SAT mosquitoes are also not
competitive with wild-type and they will
not be able to spread
they will just essentially be diluted
and fallout from a population so what is
a solution the solution is a dream Drive
and let me explain what is a dream drive
is game drive has the ability to spread
in a population even if they decrease
the fitness of animals in which the teen
drive results many natural gene drives
are known
there are ultimate selfish genes so
there is a logical solution we can
reverse engineer the natural gene Drive
and add the genes which induce pathogen
resistance may transgenic mosquitoes and
then spread these mosquitoes in the
population and they will spread and this
idea was suggested in 2003 by Austin
bird and at that point it seems like it
was unattainable
let me also describe how actually gene
Drive walk D Drive forces their
preferential inheritance into the next
generation progeny by coping themselves
or by killing the gammas which do not
carry them so this diagram will explain
it in the normal been dealing
inheritance mosquito is a diploid
organism so it has one homologous genes
from a mother the arm of homologous gene
from the father so there is always two
copy of the same gene so if we have a
transgenic mosquitoes and it has one
copy of a gene which is way both red on
this diagram
so only one homologous chromosome will
carry it and it has 50% of chance to be
inherited by a progeny but if you look
at the diagram you'll go for generation
down these frequency 50% will diminish
to a little bit more than 12 percent
after four generation so this means that
we have a dilution effect these changes
get diluted and it's not gonna spread
whereas the gene drive that gene which
is sitting on one Kamala's chromosome
can't copy itself in the other
homologous chromosome which do not have
it and now both chromosomes
will happen and the frequency of
transmission will be hundred percent and
then we go for generation down and it
still stays hundred percent gradual
Mandor who basically figure out these
inheritance lower back and hundred years
ago would be very surprised if he would
discover something like a dream drive at
his time and it all became possible with
a discovery of the CRISPR CRISPR
essentially permitted some engineering
of synthetic gene drive CRISPR stands
for clustered regulatory interspaced
short palindromic repeats it is a part
of a big adaptive immunity system in
bacteria and scientists reverse-engineer
how these CRISPR system works in
bacteria instead using parts of it for
gene editing in all our animals and one
protein cast line in particular and cast
line stands for CRISPR associated
protein number nine is a very very good
protein out of the CRISPR system it is
essentially RNA guided caesars of DNA it
became very popular because it is very
easy to program cast line which part of
the gene to cut and cut line operates in
a very diverse organisms and next slide
show you how cast line can walk as a
programmable DNA scissors so cast line
is a protein by itself it's not doing
anything
it needs guide RNA so essentially guide
the cast line to a specific location
based on complementarity so the guide
RNA will go will find location and then
cast nine can become active and cut that
targeted sequence and induce
double-stranded cap in the DNA cells
they do not like to have double stranded
cuts because they're very mutagenic
they will commit apoptosis or tried
fix and ligate these cuts and one
pathway called em joining is simply
excels just going and stitching to the
other piece these breaks and then
frequently it induces mutation at the
cut location
alternatively you can also do homology
directed repair where it use the region
on the koala boost chromosome as a
template for repair
you can view Danny's diagram during this
repair process essentially homologous
chromosome can't copy itself and if it
has some extra material it can basically
copy that material into the cut naive
chromosome and then that homolog
essentially will be spread on both
copies when this process is called
homology directed repair so now let's
see how gene drive work so here you see
two chromosome one homologous chromosome
and then do not carry the team called
naive chromosome the other one the
carrier carry stream drive so Jane dry
phonetic make cut and then copy itself
and now this mosquito will go and meet
with a wild-type counterpart and the
process will be repeated
and then we'll go down multiple
generation
and then g-drive spreads it is important
to understand that the tissue can be of
two different kind one carrot is a germ
cells that are kinda somatic cells and
germ cells do not mean that they are
packaging or bacteria it means that the
single germ cell can develop or
germinate into the entire organism which
will have comedians somatic tissue so
each organism can be fought as somatic
tissue which contains some germ cells
inside my hand on my on my hat is a
somatic tissue somatic tissue is mortal
it will die with me it has a lot of
differentiated cells it has a lot of
mutations but these mutations are not
inherited it is a very important
difference between germ cells germ cells
it's essentially the gametes in my body
the game is inside the somatic tissue
they are immortal in some way they are
undifferentiated selves they are very
few mutations but these mutations I
inherited they will be passed to the
next generation the sole purpose of germ
line or germ cells is to maintain
genetic integrity and to continue sort
of inheritance to the next generation
and the whole purpose of somatic tissue
ensure and protect the germ cells not
get eaten by a predator Chinggis Khaan
essentially made Mongol Empire 800 years
ago it conquered all Russia and a lot of
Central Asia and now if you go to those
regions and if you sequence people
living in those regions quite a few
people will have some genes on the Y
chromosome specifically which will trace
their inheritance to this single man
Chingiz farm it comes up to that he was
a very prolific father so this change is
found in his genes which persisted for
more than 800 years among many people
living in the area which used to be
Mongol Empire
show
the germline in the sense can be immoral
then D drives they have to walk they
have to copy themselves in germ cells
this next slide show the actual picture
of a gene drive which is sitting in the
gene in Drosophila gene called wide
that's why W in the only carrier
chromosome gene drive has gather in a
caste nine GFP which is green
fluorescent protein so we can track
which flies have gene drive encouraging
guide RNA and cos line will be expressed
they will go and cut the naive
chromosome and then do the repair
process the whole gene drive can be
copied using the HDR or homology
directed repair the next picture shows
slightly different outlook how the
process happen and caste line is a
scissors or endonuclease it will be
guided by guide RNA to the specific site
of Kolkata and there the repair will
take place and the gene drive will
spread and gene drive can be used for
two main strategies it can be used for
population replacement where release and
green leaf tea fluorescent flies and
they will replace the wild-type flies
over many generations or they can be
used for population suppression where we
release the green fluorescent flies and
they will spread but they also
essentially will doomed population to
extinction because they carry female
infertility gene for example and so this
picture summarizes that different fields
where the gene drive can be used gene
Drive can solve very different diverse
problems replacement gene Drive can be
used used to spread disease refractory
insects it can be used to spread
immunized animals which wild animals and
they are resource potential source of
human diseases we can immunize them and
spread them all again spread enhanced
threatened species like a frog which is
succumbing
you the steam fungi we can make them
resistant to that fungi and then they
will no longer be Fred and the fresh
engine drive that can be used for
population control to essentially
eradicate invasive species by spreading
female killer gene or spreading female
infertility genes and so the bottom of
the slide summarizes that the gene
drives can can help agriculture become
safe and sustainable they can control
invasive species or we can eradicate
completely insect-borne diseases but
many gene drives were actually failing
in the lab as these three publications
show on the top diagram you see that the
red line should go up but in reality
black two lines are going down so the
key and I have started to spread but
then it falls out it turns out that the
homing or copy gene drive which could be
itself from one homologous chromosome to
another one
they also induce resistant mutations
this mutation I induced very rarely but
they will accumulate and they will block
the spread of a gene drive eventually so
let's go and figure out how these
resistant mutations originate this slide
shows the actual sequence of fatality
gene it's the white gene and blue and
pink show the actual sequence of a guide
RNA which is 23 base pairs the bottom
sequences shows amino acid sequence
which will be translated from this DNA
so the caste line and guide and I will
go and cut these sequence at specific
site and then if repair will go through
homology directed repair the gene drive
will insert itself inside this location
and knock out the gene but it will add
up to 21 thousand base pairs
alternatively if the end joining or
non-homologous end joining
pathway will face this double stranded
calf it can also insert or delete some
mutations and these mutations who
caused a loss of function of his
particular gene
but with some probability some mutations
will be induced which may be functional
mutations for example in one of them
three base pairs will be removed so one
alanine will be removed from amino acid
sequence but the whole coding frame will
be preserved or just two base pairs will
be replaced so these mutations are
functional but they are still resistant
to the ginger because guide RNA is no
longer recognized this sequence this
sequence have some changes so these in
frame functional mutations are the worst
kind of resistant mutations since they
preserve gene function image still
resistant to clean dry and that's what
basically causing the failures of the
gene track and next slide also explains
it a little bit more so in this
particular case the gene Drive supposed
to go into the gene which is called
transformer and transformer functions as
a functional gene only in the females of
flies if you put the gene drive inside
transformer transformer will be no
longer functional and then the females
will turn into the males and that's how
you can make a lot of sterile males but
if you insert some knowledge in drive
our mutations and in blue-ish you see
the example of loss of function mutation
which is still resistant to gene dr king
- no longer recognize it but it's not
going to convert female into them it's
not going to preserve the function of
the gene so the female will still turn
out to be a male because you're knocking
out their gene but in the red square you
see the fly which have in frame
functional mutation at the gene called
transformer both organism will develop
as a female and they will be completely
resistant to gene charge but they also
will sting turn up to be a female and
they will show up with a 7% probability
according to this research so that's a
weakest point of the gene drive so what
are the solutions
the solutions are we have to target
essential
Jim which is very important and any
mutation and their gene can cause little
it's your sterility we can use multiple
guide RNA to target the same gene and
amounts of publications so it will be
harder to get in frame functional
mutations or we can encode the rescue of
a targeted gene inside the gene drive so
this rescue will have different DNA
sequence which will not longer be
recognized by guide RNA but will still
be translated into the same amino acid
sequence and we may think about the gene
Drive which do not rely on homie or
coughing for its fare is any ginger
Freddie for application and yes one gene
Drive which targets double sex in
malaria mosquito is actually ready for
application in the lab these gene drive
cope itself in the female specific gene
and sterilizes female mosquitoes but it
has no effect on the male mosquitoes in
the lab if you add these transgenic
mosquito to population you see on the
graph blue and and and red lines these
spread and almost it'll become
transgenic in the cage but then this
cage will produce less and less progeny
because more and more females and
transgenic but they are also stew I'll
so this is population suppression drive
and this drive is actually now
undergoing testing in the semi field
conditions in the large cages to see
that it will not have any kind of
resistant mutations and it's very close
to application and think about it this
gene drive can suppress population of
mosquito which carries malaria and block
malaria transmission all you have to do
you just have to spread some of the
males and they will basically spread
themself you don't have to do anything
and malaria malaria will not be
transmitted in their area another gene
drive in our solution which does not
rely on coping called cleaver in rescue
this is very interesting drive because
this gene drive by a genetic addiction
essentially here the gin drive you can
think of it as a toxin an antidote the
toxin is the cast line and guide RNA
which go and cut essential gene
completely destroy it so the organism
will destroy the central gene will will
die but the gin drive itself also have
antidote as I said that's a recoded
essential gene which is resistant to
guide RNA of the toxin they also have
maybe some desirable genes and now if
you if the parents which carry cleaver
will meet with wild-type parents all the
progeny which will survive will have to
carry the cleaver G essentially anybody
who have a cleaver gene cleave on the
rescue become addicted to it you could
not live without because only only their
gene drive have an antidote and then in
the models and in actual tests it show
that if you are 25% of flies which have
glia and rescued enjoyed they spread
very fast for population our lab also
thought about our system which is non GF
which is a new version of Stirling
technique here we separate caste line
from guide RNA we essentially made
transgenic flies which have caste lined
in them in one line and the other line
have a only guide RNA in them but the
guide RNA line have two different guy
turning one guy during a targeted gene
which is important for female
development and the second guide and
they target the gene which is important
for sperm iteration we can maintain
these lines indefinitely as homozygous
line in the lab cast line does not cut
the DNA without guide RNA but then if we
cross these lines together will make a
lot of embryos and then those embryos
will develop and only still males will
come up after the development because
females will die development so we
tested and have proof of principle of
this method in Drosophila we can
generate like large numbers or just
awful are males which are completely
sterile but they are very competitive
because it's only one gene is knocked
out the gene which cause important for
sperm iteration if strangely enough
those sterile males they actually live
longer than the wild-type males there
are important thing that all females are
dying so we don't need to sex them we
don't need to separate females or males
it's done for us genetically it is very
evolutionary stable system because
resistant mutations are not induced and
they are not sampled in the nature it is
environmentally friendly specious
specific and self-limited it could not
propagate by itself as with classic a
society or still insisting you have to
release these insects multiple times and
this we call this technique
precision-guided still incest technique
so digits and tto males are not
genetically modified organisms because
they could not reproduce so maybe we can
secure our legal permission to apply
this technology sooner than for gene
drives it is also logistically scalable
system we can make a lot of facts and
move them easily so what's the future in
the future we want also to develop PG
SAT for yellow fever mosquitoes which is
invasive species they are everywhere in
seven states of america and they can
transmit a lot of diseases like dengue
fever yellow fever zika chikungunya and
our goal now is to engineer pthe system
and eradicate an institute a yellow
fever mosquitoes everywhere in u.s. and
these particular species Aedes aegypti
is especially good system for psi T
because the acts of these species can be
desiccated and they can still be viable
for one year this means we can generate
a lot of psi T X somewhere in California
and then we can deploy them anywhere in
the world and models show that PGF City
is expected to suppress yellow fever
mosquitoes much better than any current
non gene drive methods available so we
are looking forward to use this
technology and we're almost done
building this
in inside mosquitoes so in summary Chris
Pakistan technology is simplified
engineering synthetic homing genes life
but resistant mutations are still a weak
point of any home in King jive while Jim
Jeff still is very going very strong and
it's almost ready for deployment
it is suppression Drive the other kind
of a gene drive which is not homing
clever and rescue drive will advance the
development of replacement gene Jeff and
finally precision guided steel and stick
technique is a very good improved
version of SAT and it's self limited so
it can also be used for insect control
and with that I want to thank you for
your attention